yeah so um today we'll talk about
reinforcement learning
um it's a new exciting topic it will be
mostly a review there was a tutorial
yesterday that I think some of you
attended we'll go over similar similar
things
um and hopefully this is mostly a review
for you but we'll go into certain I
think into quite some detail into some
of the some some of those reinforcement
learning Concepts
um first a few reminders so
um today there is the project proposal
is due
this should be mostly helpful to you
this will be rather Light review that we
want to make sure that the project
proposals kind of make sense and you're
on the right track to doing something
exciting and then uh another reminder is
that homework 2 is due on Monday next
week and also homework 3 will be out on
Monday as well
all right so reinforcement learning is a
is a new topic in this class so I first
wanted to start with uh you know why why
should we care why should we work on
reinforcement learning and reinforcement
learning is a field that deals with
predicting long-term consequences of
your actions and then learning
intelligent behaviors based on that
and I was thinking you know how to
introduce reinforcement learning and I
was thinking of maybe showing some
applications that you might have seen
already robots grasping doing all kinds
of different things and so on but
actually I thought that maybe we could
reverse that question and given that
reinforcement learning deals with
long-term consequences of your actions
maybe we can think of actions that are
isolated that don't affect the future
right so if we figure out what are those
kind of settings then reinforcement
learning would deal with everything else
and actually thinking about this it's
quite tricky to think of an action that
doesn't influence the the future right
even if I do something kind of
meaningless I don't know like I'll tap
the microphone
right here
um you know maybe it you might think
that it doesn't affect the future at all
but maybe exerted so much energy that it
would require me to take a nap later in
the day and that would actually you know
have quite a consequence or maybe it
will distract someone listening to this
class because they hear a little bit of
a noise and then they won't attend the
class which would be you know a horrible
consequence we wouldn't want to do that
so I apologize for that
um it's actually really tricky to think
of actions that don't affect the future
and here's a little example
demonstrating this so here's uh this is
an a double pendulum uh that is the same
double pendulum just recorded six times
it starts basically from the same
initial conditions or at least
indistinguishable to us and the initial
action is the same the person just lets
it go
and let's see how it evolves
so we can see that the action seems
fairly similar the initial condition
seemed quite similar as well and
initially all of these recordings seem
basically indistinguishable it looks
exactly the same
however over time
the consequences with the slight
difference in the initial action and the
initial conditions compound quite a bit
and towards the end all of these six
recordings look completely different the
pendulum behaves in a completely
different way
this is something that is well known in
chaos fury it's also referred to as
Butterfly Effect I encourage you to look
it up but that's just one example of how
something that seems you know very small
in uh doesn't really matter at the
beginning it actually can have quite
large long-term consequences
um and so far in this class we've been
talking a lot about supervised learning
and supervised learning is one of these
cases or the the modeling in supervised
learning is one of the these cases where
we pretend that the action that we'll
take
doesn't affect the future all right so
for instance we'll be classifying cats
and dogs and we'll be looking at the
image and based on what we see in the
image we'll say you know this is a cat
and then in our modeling procedure we
pretend that this is the end right this
this is where the world ends this is
kind of the the block world that we are
in and nothing happens after after that
but in reality you know you would make a
decision whether this is a cat or not
and then this would have some further
consequences and you would use that
information somehow
so supervised learning is this very kind
of small toyish world where we've been
operating so far and reinforcement
learning allows us to make it a little
bit more realistic and think about
consequences of our actions
uh there's a lot of common applications
of reinforcement learning because of the
fact that it can model the world quite
well such as robotics there's also a lot
of reinforcement learning in language
and dialogue in autonomous driving also
maybe another example of Robotics in
business operations where we definitely
have to think about long-term
consequences or in in finance
so it's actually used in many deployed
ml systems and it's also one of the key
aspects of intelligence right like this
is how we make decisions this is how we
model our intelligent behaviors we think
about long-term consequences of what
we're doing
so I think it's a little bit closer to
to intelligence as we know it
all right so the plan for today's
lecture is the following we'll briefly
talk about the reinforcement learning
problem I hope that this will be mostly
the review so we'll just briefly talk
about the concepts and so on
uh then we'll talk about one way of
solving a reinforcement learning problem
with policy gradients
and then time permitting we'll talk
about Q learning because we'll be split
into two part the prediction part as
well as the policy Improvement part
I don't think we'll be able to go
through all of this today but it might
spill over on onto Monday's lecture
all right so let's start with the RL
problem
and for this we'll split
um we'll consider two two cases an
object classification case that you're
more familiar with this is a supervised
learning case and an object manipulation
case where let's say an agent has to
manipulating a bunch of objects and this
is an example of a sequential decision
making problem a problem that
reinforcement learning deals with
so in the supervised
we could make an assumption that we have
IID data available to us right
um it's in the IED data which we can
just take from a data set
um and we just assume that the data is
distributed
um in an ID fashion in a sequential
decision making process that's not the
case right so when I perform an action
that action would would influence would
affect the next state that I'm going to
see so because of that you know
depending on what action I'm taking I
will see different data distribution
afterwards so it's clearly not ID
in addition in in supervised learning we
have this large labeled curated data
sets that are just available to us and
we can work with them
but in sequential decision making case
this is a little bit more tricky there
will be some cases that will be
discussed where we have data sets
available to us and we have to think
about how they were generated and so on
but in general we have to answer the
question how do we collect the data in
the first place
right since the data is not distributed
ID we are the ones influencing the data
distribution so we have to think how to
collect it
and it's also a little unclear what the
labels are for the data is it are we
labeling actions are we labeling the
outcomes we want to achieve are we
labeling with you know what kind of
modality do we use for this and so on
in supervised learning we also have a
well-defined notion of success we have
our training and tester and we can
minimize that error and that defines
what we are trying to do versus in
sequential decision making it's even not
very clear what what the success mean
and how to define it
all right so let's start with a quick
terminology so so far we've been talking
about a supervised setting where you for
instance see an image and it goes
through some kind of model for instance
a deep neural network
um that is parameterized by some
parameters Theta and we have to at the
at the end we have to classify what's in
the image for instance what kind of cat
we are seeing in the image
now in our sequential decision making
process first it will be dependent on
time
but more importantly the the decision
that we'll make will influence the next
observation we're going to see so there
is this feedback loop here
then in addition to this we won't be
just classifying what's in the image but
we'll be actually performing actions in
the real world actions that have
consequences so when we see an image of
a tiger you know the actions that we
have to do that we have to choose from
actually have real world consequences
and the next observation really depends
on what action you you'll choose here
so
um in terms of the notation
OT would be we would
use it for the observations that we see
a t is the action that we perform all
right
then we'll have our policy which will
usually refer to as Pi it's Pi
parameterized with some parameters Theta
these are the ways of the of the neural
network
um which gives us the probability of an
action given the observation so Pi of 80
given o t
then we'll also have a notion of a state
and we'll talk about it in a second
and then we'll also have a policy that
acts on the state as opposed to on the
observation this is so-called a fully
observed case
so just to tell you a little bit about
the the difference between State and the
and the observation
um let's go back to uh philosophy this
is uh Plato's Cave
um this is a concept that Plato is
described in in some of his works and uh
the idea was the following so Plato was
basically thinking about how is it
possible that uh even though we see
objects that look very differently we
have these abstract Concepts that we can
refer to for instance you know even
though you see 10 000 different tables
they all look very differently you can
still refer to a concept of a table and
people understand what you mean when you
say a table right so there's some
general concepts some general idea of a
table
so the way he was thinking about it the
way he thought it works is that we
actually don't get to observe the the
true reality but we just get to observe
a reflection of the true Concepts in the
world so there's so this is us sitting
in in a cave
there is a God behind us or I guess
multiple gods behind us and then there
is a a Godly fire behind us as well and
the gods are showing
um presenting the true nature of an
object that we don't get to see
and then we only get to see the
reflection of that object projected onto
the wall in front of us and that
projection you know can take different
forms these are the different types of
tables and so on but we never actually
get to see the true nature of what a
table is
right the true nature is being hidden
from us that we can somehow refer to it
and that's how we can you know abstract
these Concepts
so using this analogy what we'll be
referring to as observation and state is
the things that we see the things that
we can actually sense or the robot can
sense are the observations and they
might not have all the data that we need
to make the perfect decision or they
might have too much data
um and the state as the true nature that
the true thing that we need to know in
order to make the perfect decision in
the world
right
so to make it a little bit more
practical
um an observation could be an image that
we see this is just directly what we
sense and then based on this image we
need to make a decision
and the state would be all the
information that we truly need to make
that decision which would be for
instance the positions and the
orientations and velocities of all the
objects in the scene and maybe the
category of these objects as well
in addition the observation may be
incomplete so we can have an occlusion
there could be a car in front of us and
we won't be able to we won't have all
the information we need to to make the
optimal decision
all right
so we are dealing with this sequential
decision making problem let's think a
little bit about how we can solve it
using the tools that we already have
so I'll switch the example to a driving
example so let's say we as input we get
an image from a camera in a car and then
as the action we need to pick the
steering angle and the acceleration for
instance
and we need to learn this policy
Pi Theta 80 of or of 80 given OT so that
we can we we know what kind of action to
take given what kind of image
so there is actually one way we can do
this that we already know we can just
apply supervised learning to it and this
is what was done in Nvidia in 2016. so
what they did is they collected a bunch
of data from Human drivers from truck
drivers collected observations and the
corresponding actions that they were
doing
put it in one big data set
and then use supervised learning to to
train that so to train our policy that
would then tell us you know what kind of
action to take given a certain
observation
so now my question to you is what do you
think could be a problem of an approach
like this yep
it because
because
that's right yeah so we'll have a lot of
positive data data that where the
drivers drive you know very comfortably
and everything makes sense but as soon
as you make a little bit of an error we
won't really have that data to tell us
how to correct that behavior yep
yes there's no temporal memory yep
that's true is that the problem
comes to your side
right yeah that's a good point yeah so
if you for instance saw a track on the
on the side for instance in a side
mirror and then you don't see it for a
second as a human you would remember
that there is still a truck there and
you shouldn't change your lane versus
here because you're seeing only one
frame at a time you'll immediately
forget about this and potentially change
the line and result in an accident
yep
yes it can it can't get better that's
true yeah we'll um we can collect more
human data and maybe with more data it
will get better but uh there is no kind
of straight A straightforward procedure
that would guarantee that will get
better with uh with more data yeah
all right cool so
um let's talk how we can do this with
reinforcement learning and in order to
do this with reinforcement learning we
have to be able to tell whether an
action is good or bad right in the
imitation learning in the supervised
learning setting we could just say every
action that the human did is a good
action and anything else you know we
don't even get to see
so we have to be able to decide which
action is better and in order to do this
we introduce a reward function
it's a reward function will tell us
which states interactions are better
than others
so for instance in the in the driving
case if we could assign High reward to
the states that are desirable for
instance we are driving smoothly maybe
fast safely and so on
and a low rewarded to the states where
we they result in collisions
all right then all of these things so
the state's actions reward function as
well as the transition dynamics that
tell us how our world evolves so the
probability of next day given the
current state and the action that we're
going to take
Define what we call a markup decision
process which is the the framework that
we're going to use to um uh in
reinforcement learning and what we'll be
solving in reinforcement learning
all right so the goal of reinforcement
learning
is to train a policy Pi Theta let's
policy those parameters by Theta that
maps from observations to actions so as
input it takes observations as outputted
outputs actions these observations
actually is a some result of a state
that we don't get to see right like
there is something in the real world and
then we just get to see the image of it
and then the uh the action and the state
result in the next state that we get to
see and we don't really get to control
these transition Dynamics this is the P
of S Prime given s given s comma a this
is just how the world works right like
given that I'm in a certain State and
I'm going to perform a certain action
I'm going to see something what's going
to happen next
so that results in the next state and
that the results in the next observation
and so on
so we can write it down as a
probosographical model
where we have all the dependencies that
we just described so we have the state
that leads to the observation then given
the observation we need to perform the
action and then given the action and a
state at certain time step
given our transition Dynamics we can
transport to the next state
so this part here is our policy Pi Theta
and this part here is our transition
Dynamics P of s t plus one given St
comma 80.
now the important part is that the
transition Dynamics are independent of
the previous state this is the
assumption that we make in the markup
decision process and this is what we
call a Markov property
so what that means is that to predict
what S3 I'm gonna see I only need to
know what A2 what S2 was and A2 was I
don't need to know anything about the
past
right this is the assumption that we
make and that makes math much much
simpler
and this is actually quite important and
it's often difficult to to to make sure
and think about that the system that
you're working with is actually markovan
actually satisfies this Mark of property
where the transition Dynamics only
depends on the previous state and the
previous action
all right so for the purpose of this of
of today's lecture and I think for most
of the course we'll make the assumption
that uh we are in the fully observable
world and we get to see the state itself
so we'll just say that the observations
are basically our states so we'll just
get rid of the observations and we'll be
mapping straight from states to actions
this would just make our annotations a
little bit simpler and the whole problem
is quite a bit simpler as well
so now let's start with a little bit of
math so
given this probabilistographical model
I'm gonna write down the joint
probability of all the probability
distributions that we see random
variables that we see in this graphical
model so this will be a joint
distribution of all the states and
actions from uh starting from time step
one up to timestamp capital T
all right and what this actually is this
joint distribution is a trajectory right
so the trajectory is just a sequence of
states and actions that happen one after
the other
now given that this graphical model we
can factorize this distribution the
following
as following so we can start with the
probability of starting with in in S1 so
this is the probability of our initial
State distribution
times this big product of the
probability of taking a specific action
in that state times the probability of
then jumping to the next state given the
action that I just picked and the state
that I was in right and we can keep
multiplying these up until capital T
yep there's a question
yeah I think there we will just end with
a probability of the action at the very
final step and that's it we'll just
finish with that action
all right so I'll be referring to to
this first term here this joint
probability distribution as Tau and this
is the probability this is the the
random variable that depicts the whole
trajectory so Tau would correspond to a
trajectory
and now the goal of reinforcement
learning is to find the parameters Theta
right here we'll be calling this Theta
star
which solve the the following equation
uh it's the ARG Max of the expectation
under our trajectory distribution which
will be referring to as Pi Theta of Tau
of the future some of the rewards that
we are going to get
so what that means is that you know we
have some kind of distribution
of our trajectory
right we get to control certain parts of
this distribution just this part we only
get to control the policy we don't get
to control the transition Dynamics and
so on this is the only kind of Knob we
have
and under this under expect of we then
take the expectation under this
distribution and we want to maximize the
sum of the rewards right so given that
well our policy will result in certain
trajectories how can we pick the right
set of parameters so that we maximize
the sum of the rewards that we'll get
all right and since this is a course
about multitask and Meta Meta learning
it's important to think about what is a
reinforcement learning task
so in supervised learning we would be we
were calling a task a data generating
distributions as well as the loss in the
reinforcement learning a task is the
whole mdp so in that case this will be
the state space the action space that we
that we get to that we get to use the
initial State distribution so the
probability of S1
the transition Dynamics as well as the
reward function itself
so the Hallmark of decision process is a
task
and it's important to note that this is
much more than just the semantic meaning
of a task right so whether you're just
you know grasping or pushing these These
are considered different tasks but uh
here we have much more strict definition
of what the task is
so just a few examples of what's uh what
different test distributions could be so
for instance in character animations
where we have characters that have to do
different tricks
this would correspond to different tasks
because the reward functions between the
different tasks will vary
we can also do character animations
where we are trying to put on or animate
how to put on a shirt or some kind of
garment
and in this case what would vary would
be the initial State distribution as
well as the as well as the Dynamics so
every piece of clothing would have
slightly different Dynamics
we can also consider a multi-robot case
where we're trying to learn a policy and
Gathering data from all kinds of
different robots and in this case what
would vary would be the state space the
action space the robots will be
controlled slightly differently the
initial State distribution as well as
the Dynamics even though they could be
performing the exact same tasks and they
could be using the same reward function
right are there any questions at this
point yep
yeah so you can use that and you can
include that in your state yeah the
state doesn't necessarily just
correspond to a position State could be
in our case could be even the whole
image
or any other questions
all right if there are no more questions
then let's talk about how we can
actually solve it
right and we can start we'll start off
something fairly simple or fairly
similar to what you've been doing before
and then we'll build on on top of that
and kind of see how we can get to a more
complex methods
all right so
um there's this anatomy of a
reinforcement learning algorithm how
that can help you to classify all kinds
of different RL algorithms and kind of
have a provide like a mental framework
that you can use to think about them
so this Anatomy looks like this we have
three boxes so we start with some way of
generating samples this is this Orange
Box
so what that means is that we just run
the policy our policy Pi in the real
world we collect the trajectories we can
score them based on a reward function
and that's it
then we have the green box here where we
fit the model to estimate the return so
the sum of the rewards and here we'll
talk about different options we can just
calculate the sum of the rewards this is
called the Monte Carlo and this is what
we'll be using in the policy gradient
which we'll talk about in a second
we can also fit a q function we'll also
talk about a little bit later
or we can estimate a model that models
the transition Dynamics
this is also used and you'll probably
discuss it in the in the lecture I think
on Wednesday next week
and then we have the blue box which
given that we collected some samples we
can fit a model to estimate the returns
now we have to have a way of improving
our policy and here we have a few
different choices so we can either take
the direct gradient on the objective
this is what we'll be doing in the
policy gradient case
we can also do an arc Max on the Q
function which is what we'll be doing in
the queue learning case which we'll talk
about
or we can optimize the policy using
other methods that people are using in
model-based learning by for instance
propagating for the model or using a
shooting method or something like that
all right so we will take a look at
policy gradients approach which is the
most direct way of optimizing the
objective we care about
so just again the objective that we care
about is the following we are trying to
find the parameters Theta that would
maximize this expectation right here so
this is the expectation of the sum of
the rewards and this is the expectation
under our trajectory distribution Pi
Theta of title
so I'll be just calling the the pure
objective I'll just call it J of theta
right this is our objective that is
dependent on our parameters Theta
so J of theta is equal to that I just
reroute it
and now because we have an expectation
here we can actually approximate this
expectation as we usually do in machine
learning with samples
right
so in that case we would take multiple
samples we'll take n samples and we will
take just the average we'll be averaging
you know for every if trajectory we'll
be averaging the sum of Rewards
so well this is what this is going to
allow us to do is just to evaluate the
objective right we are not optimizing it
yet we just want to say you know how
well am I doing based on my objective
so what that means is that
um this this expectation was under this
trajectory distribution so uh we are
approximating it with samples so what
we'll be doing will be just rolling out
the policy multiple times right so we'll
be just allowing the robot to run a few
times given our current policy
and let's say we'll collect three
trajectories like this right and in this
case n is equal to 3.
then we will score them so we will
calculate the sum of the rewards for
each one of them
and then we would sum over those those
samples from PI and that's it that would
tell us how good is our current policy
we'll take the average of all the
trajectories that we that we rolled out
and that average is telling us how well
am I performing on average how how good
is my objective right now with my
current policy Pi Theta
all right
so we can evaluate the objective now
let's think about how we can improve on
that objective right so again we start
with our objective as we had it
and I'm going to rewrite this objective
slightly as this so our objective here
instead of having the sum of rewards I'm
just going to call it R of of Tau which
is the full trajectory so this is just a
shortcut notation so it's a little bit
easier for us but it denotes the sum of
all the rewards that we get for the
trajectory
all right so now the way uh we can write
it out is we can write out this
expectation don't approximate it with
sample but actually use the definition
of the expectation and because this is a
continuous
um distribution we would write it out as
an as an integral of our PI Theta of Tau
times R of Tau D Tau
right so we have this ugly integral here
and we have to do something with it
but now we want to improve on that
objective and the way we usually improve
on objectives in whether machine
learning is we do gradient descent right
so we compute the gradient with respect
to our parameters of the objective and
then we perform the gradient the center
Ascent procedure to improve on on the
objective
so let's try to let's try to write out
the the gradient of our objective
so we can start by just you know adding
gradient of with respect to parameters
fade of our objective and we can
actually swap or swap the order between
the integral and the and the and the
gradient itself these are two linear
operations you're you're allowed to do
that
and now we have a little bit of a of a
problem right so we have this very awful
gradient we have to integrate over all
kinds all trajectories
and then we need to not only do this but
we also need to take a gradient with
respect to all of this and this is this
distribution the trajectory distribution
which we don't really get to control
so the first thing that we want to deal
with is that this this grade this this
integral is not tractable right like we
are not able to you know integrate over
all kinds of trajectories
so when we when we have that what we
usually try to do is try to somehow
change it back to an expectation so
let's try to do that
trying to do that so
what we will have in this case
is that
we have our
let's just write it like this we have
our gradient with respect to parameters
Theta
of
Pi Theta
of Tau
right this is the the first term that we
have in that under that under that
equation and what would we the way we
would want to change it
is that we would want to somehow pull
the the distribution of Tau
in front of the integral so that then we
can take the expectation right because
we have here some integral
here is
our gradient operator and then we have a
bunch of stuff here including our
distribution
Pi Theta of Tau
and what we want to do is somehow pull
that pie in here because if and this is
detail
right because if we do that then once we
have the integral and here we have the
probability distribution Pi Theta of Tau
then we can just say that this is the
expectation under
Pi style of Pi Theta of tan
right and then we can just keep whatever
was
was inside here in there and once we
have the expectation we can approximate
it with samples and we're good we don't
have to do the integral
so now what we want to do is take that
what we have right now and somehow
change it such that we have pi
Pi Theta of Tau
times some kind of gradient
of something right
so the question is well that's something
what is that something so we have to do
a little bit of arithmetic to get there
so let's try to do that
and to do this I'm going to tell you
about a certain identity that should
come in very handy
so that identity is
I think you might you might be familiar
with it it's fairly straightforward
it says that the gradient with respect
to X of log of
f of x
is equal to can anybody tell me what
this is equal to
you remember that
yep
one over f of x times the gradient with
respect to X of f of x
that's right okay a simple identity
so now what we can do is let's multiply
both sides by f of x
so if we do that
what we'll end up with I'm just going to
write it here is we'll have f of x
grad X log
f of x is equal grad X
f of x
all right I just multiply both sides by
f of x
all right so now we have
an interesting formula here
that actually gives us the answer to
what we want so we want to somehow
transform this this part grad with
respect to Theta of Pi Theta of Tau
2 pi Theta of Tau times the gradient of
something
so the part that we have on the left
side here is what we have on the right
side right here right this is just
instead of X we have Theta here and
instead of f of x we have Pi of Tau
Pi Theta of time
all right so then the the missing part
here would be we have f of x which is
that part here by Theta of Tau this this
checks out and then we have the gradient
with respect to X gradient with respect
Theta the only missing part is the log
of f of x so in this case this would be
log
of Pi Theta
of Tau
right
so we just transformed it slightly and
this way using this this lock trick this
this simple identity we can actually so
I'm just going to write this down right
here this is just I'm repeating exactly
the same thing that I wrote on the board
and this is how we can rewrite it and
this is just what we what we got to on
the on the Whiteboard as well
and now given that we can go back and
roll it back into the into an
expectation right so now we have the
integral and under our integral we have
a probability distribution of Tau D Tau
so we can use the definition of an
expectation and roll it back into the
expectation and just say this is the
expectation under the distribution of Pi
Pi Theta of Tau of the term that was
inside in there which is this grad log
pi times r
all right
so what we did so far is we came up with
a formula that gives us the gradient
with respect of our with respect to our
objective and we got rid of this
integral that was a little nasty
so there's one more piece right we had
two nasty things one was the integral
and the other thing was that we have
this uh Pi Theta Pi Theta of Tau which
is the whole trajectory distribution and
we don't really control the whole
trajectory distribution we only control
the policy this is the only part that is
dependent on the parameters Theta
so let's just write it out
so this is our PI Theta of Tau this is
just I wrote out the whole Tab and this
is the factorization that we had before
so this is pi Theta of Tau
and let's take the log of both sides
because we need to log
here
so if we take the log on on both sides
we see that the product the log of the
product is the sum of the of the logs so
we do that
and now we can just substitute whatever
we got here under here so let's do that
so we are substituting substituting this
log Pi Theta of Tau with all the terms
that that we used in the factorization
so this is the now the initial State
distribution our policy and the Dynamics
right and our policy is the only part
that is dependent on the parameter on
the parameters Theta
and we take the the gradient with
respective Theta of that
right so if we do that can you tell me
what would be the gradient of this term
with respect to Theta
zero that's right and what about this
term
it's here as well yeah that's right
these two terms are now dependent on
Theta we take the gradient with respect
to Theta these are zero they cancel out
and what we end up with is a Formula a
formula like this where the gradient
with respect to our objective is just
this expectation and there are
trajectory distribution Pi Theta of Tau
of the sum of this gradlock pi and this
we can actually evaluate right this is
this is our neural network this is the
neural network that given an input State
outputs an action we can take the the
log of that computer gradient that's
okay and we then multiply it by the sum
of the rewards
all right so now we have a way of
actually having a gradient of the
objective so we can now improve on our
objective
so let's try to evaluate it first so the
same way as we're evaluating the
objective how would we evaluate the
gradient of that objective
so this is I'm just rewrote the the
formula and recall that we were able to
before approximate the expectation with
samples from our trajectory
so let's do the exact same thing here
so we will be approximating this
gradient with a bunch of samples these
are samples from our trajectory
so we'll have n different rollouts and
we'll be averaging over these terms for
each one of these Rollins
and then once we do that then we have
our gradient then we can perform our
gradient Ascent procedure to improve our
parameters so that our objective gets
better and better
right are there any questions at this
point yep
[Music]
could you repeat the question please
well what explains the difference
between the trajectories
right so how is it that if you roll out
a single policy you it results in three
different trajectories
yeah so there's multiple differences so
first thing what could happen is that
your policy is stochastic right so the
policy is a probability distribution of
actions given a state
so then according to the probability
distributions you will be picking
slightly different actions every time
that's one thing the other thing is that
the Dynamics itself can be stochastic as
well
right so given a certain State and
action sometimes it will result in a
certain S Prime sometimes it will result
in a slightly different S Prime and
that's what correspond to to differences
in the way you you roll out the policy
and this will result in different
trajectories
right are there any other questions
all right cool
so what we did here is in terms of the
anatomy of our RL algorithm we have the
generate samples part which is the part
that we have here we just roll out a
bunch of policies a few times
then we fit the model to estimate the
return so the green box in our case is
this we just sum the rewards that we got
for these trajectories
and then to improve the policy the blue
box we are just doing the gradient
Ascent procedure we computed the
derivative with respect to our objective
and you know we'd upgrade in ascent and
our policy gets better
and this results in the Sim one of the
simplest RL algorithms called rainforce
and it works exactly how you would
imagine we sample a bunch of
trajectories so we run the policy
then we compute the derivative with
respect to our objective according to
our formula that we just established
and then we perform gradient ascent and
we do it over and over again right so
then we improve our policy then we roll
out this new policy again and we keep
going
all right
so just a one quick side note here we
also talked about imitation learning
right and in imitation learning what you
would do is you would do maximum
likelihood
so the policy grading formula is written
right here this is what we just
discussed
but in the imitation learning case which
we discussed for you know people from
Nvidia were just collecting the data and
trying to fit our policy to be uh to
replicate what the human drivers did
the objective would be to maximize the
log likelihood so we were trying to
maximize the likelihood of our data
given the model
and the objective would actually look
like this and it would be very very
similar to The Objective you see up here
that we just derived with the policy
gradient
so could you tell me
um what's the difference and or how can
we make the policy gradient look exactly
the same as the maximum likelihood
so how can we make our RL algorithm
behave exact same way
as uh as a as an imitation learning
objective yep
constantly you can give it constant
reward what kind of reward
or
something
um
right the reward would need to be
constant but it would need to be
constant for specific actions the same
actions of the humans did right
yeah
you're about to say okay yeah so we
would need to reward the actions that
the humans did let's say with the reward
one at the very end of the trajectory
and every other action would be would be
zero and in this case the policy
gradient would correspond exactly to
doing imitation learning
all right cool
so a little bit of intuition of what's
what's happening here if you maybe got
lost a little bit in the in the math
so we have our reinforce algorithm we
have our objective
um this objective is fairly similar to
the maximum likelihood objective but
what that actually mean means is that we
would look at our trajectory
distribution we would roll it out so we
that would result in this free
trajectories let's say so our trajectory
distribution will look like this this
heat map that you can see underneath
right so certain trajectories will be
more likely than others
and then through our policy gradient we
would shift our probability Mass towards
the trajectories that achieve higher
reward right so it's dependent on the
sum of rewards right here so the the
trajectories or the actions that result
in higher Rewards
would uh we would increase their
likelihood
and actions that result in lower rewards
will decrease their likelihood
right so then we would change our
trajectory distribution to move towards
the trajectories that achieved higher
returns
so basically it makes the good stuff
more likely and the bad stuff less
likely it just formalizes the notion of
trial and error it just formalizes it
mathematically
all right so to summarize
um the pros of policy gradients is that
it's fairly simple it's easy because of
that it's fairly easy to combine with
existing multitasking meta learning
algorithms and we'll talk about it in
the next class
and in terms of cons the the gradient
that you see here
you can barely see my pointer
this this gradient the this estimate of
this gradient actually has very high
variance so people usually use various
tricks to reduce that variance so in
practice it's usually used with
so-called bass lines people use stress
regions and all kinds of different
tracks to make it better
but it also requires on policy data and
what I mean by this is the following so
this expectation here is with respect to
our the trajectory distribution induced
by our current policy Pi Theta right so
we iteratively have to be running our
current policy all the time we don't we
can't really look at the data that we
generated in the past we can only look
at the data that we generated right now
the policy is improving with every
iteration
so we cannot reuse existing experience
to estimate the gradient we can only use
the current experience which is actually
a really big limitation
and this is something we'll we'll
discuss a little bit more
we can sort of do it with important ways
but it produces even higher variance and
this is this is quite tricky to get to
work
all right so to just briefly tell you
what's on policy versus off policy
um the on policy means that the data has
to come from the current policy as it is
in the in the policy gradient case
it's compatible with all RL algorithms
so any algorithm you'll learn about it's
possible to run it on policy so that
means you're generating the data and
then you're using that data that you
just generated to improve that policy
but it cannot reuse data from previous
policies so you can only use the data
that you just generated with your
current policy
as opposed to of policy where data can
come from any policy and we'll learn
about it in a second
it works with specific RL algorithms
with value-based reinforcement learning
algorithms
and it's much more sample efficient
because now we can do gradient steps on
the old data as well so we can be
reusing the data many many times as
opposed to just running the the policy
once generating the data and you can
only use the data in this moment and
then you will improve the policy the
policy will change and you have to
generate the data again
all right so
are there any questions regarding policy
grades yep of course you know if I
change the uh something stretched in
Minecraft
so the question is if you change
yeah I see so what would happen if you
change that expectation to be under some
other distribution if you change your
sampling strategy so you sample from
something else
with that
I just changed
I see so if you change your sampling
strategy but you would still use the
current policy I think what that would
mean if you would mean if you mean like
you would just do uniform sampling
uniform sampling of trajectories
that's not really feasible to do or you
would have to have a uniform policy then
right so the policy would assign the
same probability to every action that it
can perform and then that would be the
uniform sampling strategy of
trajectories but then you're changing
the policy
Jenner three introductories
I assemble ways to more recently
connected
okay so you would still generate the
trajectories the same way but then you
would use them to estimate the
expectations differently
yeah so you can do that and you usually
people do this with important sampling
which tells you exactly how you should
change those and how you should sample
them so that you adjust for the
probabilities of your current policy but
that results in even higher variants so
that's tricky to do but yeah it's
possible
yep
it is
[Music]
foreign
so just to repeat the question
um you're saying that uh in this case
you can't really change the policy that
you're doing the rollouts with you can't
add noise to it or something like this
and if you just you know by luck you're
just got really high return for that
particular policy because you just
rolled it one rolled it up rolled it out
once then you would move your your shift
your probability Mass towards that
policy even though you're just lucky and
yeah this is the problem with high
variants so you're just estimating the
entire objective based on funeral outs
or a single rollout in this case and if
you're just lucky then you didn't
estimate that gradient correctly
um and then you know you'll shift the
distribution Mass towards the thing that
you shouldn't be really shifting in
um and we'll talk about how we can
improve on that yeah this is a great
question
all right cool
all right so we talk about of policy and
on policy so there is one more small
note that I wanted to to make here
so let's take a look at our formula here
again this is our policy gradient
formula
and I'm going to make a slight
transformation of this formula here so
what we are doing here is we are summing
bunch of terms in this
parentheses and then we are multiplying
it by a bunch of terms that we are
summing as well in this parentheses
so basically this corresponds to
something like
this we have
a plus b plus c
right times X Plus y plus Z
right
so what we can do instead is we can
rewrite this as a times X Plus y plus Z
Plus B times X Plus y
see let's see
it's X Plus y plus Z right so this is
just a slice of we write
so let's do that here what this would
result in is we can now we'll be summing
over
where's
let me just show it with my hand so
we'll be summing over all of these terms
and each one of these terms will be
multiplied by the sum of the rewards
right this is the exact same
transformation that we just did on the
Whiteboard
right so let's do that but now there is
one thing that is a little peculiar so
we are summing for a particular action
that we took at a certain time step t
for a trajectory I
we will be evaluating this and we'll be
potentially increasing the likelihood of
that action based on the sum of all of
the rewards that we achieved for that
entire trajectory so starting from time
step one up until the end
right so in other case we have this
whole trajectory that we are looking at
and we are in a particular point in that
trajectory let's say in this green point
right here
right
and now we are summing all of the
rewards the rewards that came before
that we we are taking this action and
what the rewards that came after we took
that action and we use that entire sum
to tell us whether this action was good
or bad
right can anybody tell me what's what's
wrong with that
yep
that's right yeah so the action that
can't really control the past right like
it only influences the future
so that we can do instead is we can just
sump together the rewards starting from
that action moving forward and this
would actually reduce the variance of
our estimate
so we can do this slight change and
instead of
summing the rewards at time step one we
can sum the rewards starting at time
step T at the recurrent times of where
we're at
and this is what we call the reward to
go so this is how much more reward there
is left starting from this action up
until the end
yep
for everybody
um yes but the variance of the estimate
will be lower that's right
all right so this summarizes our policy
graving part and now let's talk about Q
learning so this would allow us this is
we'll talk about off policy algorithms
that where we don't need to have this uh
you know assumption where you have to
roll out the policy and you can only use
those samples to improve it and it's
generally the very exciting area of
reinforcement learning research and it's
used all over the place and it's very
commonly used in robotics where we very
much care about data efficiency and we
want to take multiple gradient steps
over the same data
all right so we talked about the anatomy
of reinforcement learning algorithm and
we talked about one particular way of of
doing reinforcement learning which is
with policy gradients so directly
optimizing in the objective doing the
gradient Ascent procedure and this is
how we can approximate this gradient
and this this green part here
corresponded or the the sum of rewards
corresponds to the green box where we
are trying to fit a model to estimate
the return
here we do multiple rollouts to that
corresponds to The Orange Box and the
whole thing corresponds to improving the
policy this is the gradient procedure
all right so now let's think a little
bit how we can improve on that policy
gradient and the exact way I would like
to improve is by improving the green box
so we'll try to improve that estimate of
the of the rewards to go
all right
so let's call this some kind of estimate
we somehow we need to estimate how what
kind of reward we are going to get
starting from a current time Step Up
Until the End if I continue with this
policy and let's call this estimate the
estimate of the reward to go Q hat for
the particular trajectory I at the
specific time step t
so this is the estimate of our expected
reward if we take in a specific action
AIT in the state sit
now can we get a better estimate of that
rewards to go than what we are currently
doing
and for this let's go back to our little
trajectory plot
so uh right now what we are doing is we
are summing together all of the rewards
starting at our
starting at our Green Dot up until the
end and we're summing the the rewards
that we got from this trajectory that
we're actually executing in the world
all right so
um this is this is how we are we are
just summing the rewards that we got for
that specific trajectory
all right so let's now imagine that we
are trying to do this for our life
all right so let's say you're trying to
evaluate certain decision that you that
you made in your life let's say you
decided to apply to Stanford
all right and now you want to
estimate how good was that decision
right and the way we want to do this or
the way we are doing it here is that you
wait until the very end of your life
and then you look back at all the
rewards that you gathered starting from
you know the decision that you made to
apply to Stanford up until the very very
end you know you're on your deathbed
thinking about this
and then based on this based on the sum
of these rewards you can now tell you
know was that action good or bad
all right
so there was this movie and I apologize
for spoilers I don't think that's too
big of a spoiler but uh let's just think
about this movie there's this movie
called about time
um where the main character I think his
name is Tim uh he gets to travel in time
all right so I think the way it works is
that uh he just needs to close his eyes
and close his fists really hard and then
think of a moment where he wants to get
back to and then he can just live his
life kind of again from that moment on
all right
so now if Tim were to evaluate his
decision to apply to Stanford
what he would do is that he would go
back to that point where he made that
decision or to the time step right after
this and live multiple lives right so
live that life many many times and kind
of go to the very end calculate all of
the rewards and then teleport back in
time to the decision when you know he
decided to apply to Stanford and then
live that life again
so his estimate of the rewards to go
would be much much better than yours
right your estimate is just based on
your life and maybe you know
um there was a little bit of luck
involved and uh your life turned out to
be an amazing life but it actually
didn't have anything to do with you
applying to Stanford you were just maybe
you know you won the lottery a little
bit later and it just you know uh seemed
like this was an extremely happy life
and you you thought that the reward to
go was very high but it's just because
of the stochasticity of the Dynamics but
Tim would be able to you know live that
life many many times and kind of
integrate out all the little you know
lucky and unlucky things so that he can
actually tell you know what's the reward
to go if I apply to Stanford
all right
so Tim can estimate the future sum of
rewards this is still with respect to
under the expectation of of Tim of Pi
Theta so he still lives as Tim every
single time right like he doesn't make
random actions after this he he's just
him see he behaves like Tim the entire
time
so but his estimate of the rewards to go
is much better than us right
so we we called the Q hat the estimate
of the expected reward so let's call Q
the true expected reward to go right so
this is the actually the true uh
expected under the the expectation under
our current policy of the rewards that
we are gonna of the sum of the rewards
we're gonna experience
and now if we if we could do this if we
could somehow get a better estimate of
the rewards to go
then the entire then the entire gradient
estimate would be better right so
because we would be improving on this
the whole gradient would be better
so basically Tim Not only would be able
to better estimate you know how many
rewards are there to go based on the
decision but he would also be able to
make better decisions
right
so now let's introduce three concepts
here so first this this function q that
we were talking about which is the
estimated the the expected sum of
Rewards
um let's continue calling it q and this
would be the sum of the rewards under
the expectation of our current policy
given that we start at a certain State
doing certain action so this is the
total reward uh that we would get from
taking action 80 in state SD and then
following our policy so in fact we
shouldn't just call it q but this Q is
also dependent on our policy so let's
call it Q Pi so this is the the Q
function uh you know given the current
state and the action we're going to take
and then we continue acting according to
our policy Tim continues being Tim
there's a question
oh it's a good reasonably instructions
yeah
yeah that's a that's a good question so
the question was do we get to act for a
certain number of time steps or do we
get to act up until the very last state
or some kind of final State and these
are two different formulations and you
can you can do either one you can do the
the time based version where you act for
a certain number of time steps capital T
or you can do the infinite Horizon
reinforcement learning where instead you
introduce a little discount factor that
allows you to deal with the math yeah
cool
all right so we have the Q function
now let's introduce also another
function V we'll call it the value
function and the value function would be
just the expectation of our Q function
according to our policy under our policy
so it's very similar to The Q function
except the Q function you had the the
choice of picking any action you want at
the current time step right the Q
function is dependent on that action so
Tim can decide to apply to Stanford do
something else I don't know do something
completely random and so on but after he
makes that decision he just continues
acting as Tim he doesn't have any
freedom anymore
versus in value function Tim gets to
teleport to a certain State and he gets
to act as Tim straight away he can't
really try different things and do
something completely random that is very
unlike Tim
all right and then we also have the
advantage function uh which we call a pi
of SD comma 80. which is just the
difference between the two
so it's the difference between the Q
function and the value function and that
just tells us how much better is the
action 80 compared to the standard
action that the team would have taken
right so this is just how much better is
action 80 compared to our the action
that the policy would have picked
all right
so now one way we can rewrite our policy
gradient is rather than summing the sum
of the rewards that we got for the for
the particular trajectory we can use the
advantage function or the Q function or
something like that
all right
all right so
um now in terms of the anatomy of our
algorithm what we are changing is that
we are still generating samples but to
fit a model we will now fit a model to
estimate the returns we want to just sum
the returns the rewards that we got for
that specific trajectory but instead
we'll try to fit our Q function value
function or the advantage function we
have these three things that we can use
that help us estimate the future Rewards
and then to improve the policy we'll
continue doing our gradient Ascent
procedure
all right
so you know we just introduced these
three new Concepts so I wanted to run a
little exercise to see if uh if that
makes sense so the exercise is the
following you're this little stick
figure
um
and you start at some SST
and your dream is to become a drummer
right and what that what that means is
that you will be evaluated a month from
now
on this drummer test
and you get a reward equal one if you
can play it and uh if you can play it in
a month and zero otherwise right so
you'll be evaluated in a month on how
good are you at achieving your dream of
becoming a drummer
and now you have three actions that you
can do one action is just chill just do
don't do anything
the second action is that you can watch
other drummers perform you can watch
videos of them and try to learn from
that
and the third actions you can actually
practice drumming and you can play and
try to get better that way
then your current policy is the
following your current policy is that
you always take action A1 you always
want to chill
right and all of the probability masses
for that action so you will always do
that
so now my question is what's the value
function V Pi of St
yes
right yeah so the value function is most
likely zero because we want to be
yeah unless you're recipient yes
uh well you know let's consider this in
in real life right so like you're being
born right now and these are the actions
you can do at your current so the t is
equal zero or maybe that shouldn't be in
the month that should be in like 10
years or something
um and then the reward function itself
is not stochastic right the reward
function given a state and an action so
given you playing the drums can tell you
did you play it or not right it will
give you a reward one or zero sorry
the probability of you can't play that
even you you don't practice
right
um yeah so for the purpose of this of
this exercise we would assume that yeah
so there's no stochasticity in their
transition Dynamics that's somehow by
luck you can you can play it yeah or
you'll just like randomly play the drums
and somehow it ended up being that you
played what they ask you to play and the
probability of that is zero yeah
all right cool so the value function is
zero
now what's the Q function
the Q of Pi
somebody else maybe
maybe yes
in this case yeah and that's the part of
the question what do you think it is
so you have to the answer is a little
bit longer than just uh the value
function case
0.001
foreign
value so Q function just tells you the
predicted sum of future rewards right so
this is just a single scaler
yeah
right yeah so the answer that you gave
was that uh it would be zero for all the
actions so what that means is that the Q
for St comma 80 where 80 equals A1
would be zero because it will be exactly
the same as the value function right you
continue doing nothing you continue
chilling
um if it was A2 so Q Pi of s t comma A2
would be maybe a little bit higher but
over zero maybe you'll learn like a tiny
tiny bit maybe there's a tiny bit of
probability that you know you somehow
learn how to play it but you're saying
probably not zero again
and now A3 means that you only decided
to play in that time step right you
decided to practice this one time step
but after this you continue acting as
you with your policy pie which is to
always show
so that means you decide to practice
once and then you chill afterwards
so you're saying it will still be zero
let's give it a benefit of the doubt
maybe it will be a little bit higher
right you at least practice once
yep
that's correct that's correct so given a
specific State and a specific action
it's one number
here because we are you know choosing
between three different actions we have
to say you know for that action will be
this number for this action will be that
number for that action will be a
different number
so the Q function kind of thinks about
the immediate action that you can take
and then you act according to your
policy afterwards
all right cool
now one more question was the advantage
function
so a pi over s t comma 80.
yeah zero
yes so it will be the same as the Q
function because the value function is
zero so the advantage function is the
difference between the Q function and
the value function
right so because in our case the value
function was Zero it would be exactly
the same as the as the Q function
right does that make sense are there any
any questions on that
all right cool
all right so there's one more thing that
I wanted to ask about so you know before
we were talking about summing together
the rewards from the trajectories that
we actually experienced
now we talked a little bit how we can do
this a little bit better like kind of
Tim how Tim was doing this but Tim still
had to live his life till the very end
to evaluate that action that he took you
know sometime in his 20s let's say
so let's consider the game of chess
and uh you know in the game of chess
let's say you get a reward one at the
very end if you win and reward zero if
you lose
and uh you know what we discussed so far
just talks about predictions right like
how well can you predict the sum of the
future rewards so how well can you
predict whether you're gonna win in
chess match or whatever you're gonna
lose
and so far what we've been talking about
is that
um
you know how like every time you would
update your predictions uh you would
have to wait until the very end of the
game
to tell whether you know to update your
belief about the game you would have to
wait you make a move and then after you
made that move you have to wait you know
continue playing the game and then the
very very end once you get all the
rewards you get the reward one or zero
you'll be able to tell oh well I was
wrong
right but that's not actually how it
works right so like what happens if you
don't finish the game what happens if
you made a move right you thought that
it was a good move and but to update
that that prediction that model of yours
you had to wait till the very very end
but let's say you went until the very
very end except for the very last move
and uh you know the power ran out or
something and you never finish the game
of chess but you're just one move you
know away from being checkmated
right so you're about to update your
belief but you never finished the game
so sorry you know you don't get to
update your prediction
so in in reality we don't always wait
till the end right like you can update
your prediction right after you made
that move right so like you made a move
and then you realize in the very next
moment oh I screwed up right like this
is my probability of winning actually
went down significantly I don't have to
wait till the very end of the game
I can update it immediately after the
move
all right so let's try to do that
and we'll do this
um on the example where we're trying to
fit we're trying to actually learn the
value function
so we'll try to learn it using
supervised learning so we'll do
supervised regression where we have our
value function which is a neural network
that takes us input some State outputs a
single scalar value
and it's parameterized by some
parameters Phi
and we need some kind of Target labels
for that value function
all right
all right so this is our this is our
value function it just has a single
output a single scalar
so now our ideal Target would be the
true expected sum of rewards given that
we start at a certain State okay but we
don't really have access to that
now the Monte Carlo Target what we've
been using before in policy gradients
would be just the sum of the rewards
that we got for that specific trajectory
up until the very end
all right
now one thing that we can see is that we
can
approximate this and this is actually a
very good approximation with the
following we can take the reward that we
got at the current time step
plus the sum of the rewards so the True
Rewards to go the true expected reward
starting from St Plus 1.
right so this is kind of like our value
function is equal the reward that I got
in this state plus the state that I
actually experienced in my trajectory
and the expected value from from that
state now can anybody tell me why this
is an approximation here
any ideas yep
right so this is a final you're saying
that this this is a final time step
problem so we have a final number of
time steps yeah that that's not exactly
it right because it would still work
even though we are summing
um you know uh over a certain number of
time steps T
um this this should still work right
like regardless whether this is an
infinite horizon or finite Horizon yep
at a few
yes that's correct Yeah so basically the
approximation is here because we this St
plus one
this is the state that we actually
experience in our trajectory
right so it's kind of like let's go back
to Tim example what Tim would do is he
would perform one action
Grant he would teleport to a certain
moment in time he would take one action
and then he would say you know let's
have let's calculate the value of
everything that I've done after this and
let's just say that it's equal to my
value at the previous state is the
reward that I got plus everything that I
experienced after this single action but
he still just took this one action right
like we still just teleported to the
next state
and this is from the actual trajectory
that we've experienced so this St plus
one this is a small approximation that
we're doing here
right now one thing that we can notice
is that
um even though this is an approximation
it's not too bad of an approximation
we're just making this one step we just
think that we took this one action and
we experienced a certain St plus one but
we can notice that this part here is
actually the value function at the next
state
right on the state at the next time step
so this is a little recursive right or
the target at the at the current state
is equal the reward that we got at the
State plus the values at the next day
and we can approximate it actually even
more or actually it will be a less
accurate estimate by saying that this
would be equal to the reward at the
current time step plus the the value
that we right now have our fitted value
so V Pi with the parameters Phi
um of s t plus one so basically we'll be
fitting this over and over and then
we'll be using that estimate that neural
network to give us the label for the for
the previous state
all right so in that case our training
data would be the state and the target
would be the reward plus the value so
what we actually are estimating at the
next state
right so this is a little recursive and
this would be our Target and this is
what we would sometimes refer to as the
bootstrap estimate we are estimating the
value function bootstrapping it from
itself
cool and a few examples this is actually
this policy evaluation that's estimating
value function is has been used many
times originally it was used in the in
the game of backgammon where the reward
was the game outcome whether you win or
lose and the value function would
correspond to the expected outcome given
a board state so we would look at the
board and the value function will tell
you how likely it is that you're going
to win
it was also used in the exact same way
in alphago where computer was playing
against the the human champion of go
and the reward was the game outcome and
the value function was exactly the same
it was a neural network that by looking
at the board it was able to tell you are
you going to win or not right and the
value function was fitted in this way
cool so we had our reinforce algorithm
that we were using before where we were
just rolling out the samples and then we
are estimating the gradient and for the
estimation we're using the sum of the
rewards that we have experienced
and now we arrived at a slightly
different algorithm which we call an
online actor critic algorithm
so in that case we will take the action
according to our policy
we'll update our value function using
the Target that we just described so the
value function of the current state is
equal the reward plus the value function
of the next state and here it's a little
discounted but you can ignore that this
is to deal with the infinite or infinite
Horizon RL
so we are filling the value function
then we can evaluate the advantage
function and we can do this by just
saying the advantage function of s comma
a is equal the reward for that state in
action plus the value at the next State
minus the value so this is our Q
function in other words minus the value
at the current state
and given the disadvantage function we
can now compute this gradient a little
bit better because now we have a better
estimate of the rewards to go and this
is what we can use the advantage
function for and we can perform gradient
descent or gradient Ascent in this case
all right cool so this is just the
prediction part and we're gonna end
right here
um
um are there any questions yep
yes this is so you can estimate the
advantage of policy but you you have to
do this step on policy
because
yeah so we'll talk about it on Monday
yeah that's a great question
right are there any other questions
no Okay cool so yeah uh on Monday we'll
talk about how we can actually improve
the policy using these Concepts and uh
hope to see you there thank you